le vérificateur général était sur le
point de remettre son rapport jusqu'à la
toute dernière minute les sénateurs ont
évité de se mouiller et moi on est lié
par un pacte de confidentialité
or radio canada a appris que les trois
sénateurs responsable de coordonner la
réponse rapport du vérificateur général
sont eux-mêmes montré du doigt il s'agit
du nouveau président du sénat léo
housakos du leader conservateur claude
carignan et de celui de l'opposition
libérale james kawano selon nous sources
il ne figure pas dans les cas les plus
graves qui seront référées à la grc
mais des milliers de dollars sont quand
même en jeu dans le cas de claude
carignan environ 3000 dollars ont déjà
été remboursés par un employé donc j'ai
pas des dépenses personnelles à moi
c'est sur le compte de n'est pas en soi
mais employés mais les housakos à qui on
réclame environ 6000 dollars et james
cameron qui lui devrait un peu plus de
10000 annonce d'emblée qu'ils vont
contester les conclusions du
vérificateur général ne dépensez pas mon
dépenses personnelles c'est pas mon
argent personnel ces deux erreurs qui
était fait en bons fois pour des
employés
on me reproche dit-il de m'être fait
rembourser des dépenses personnelles ce
n'est pas le cas martèle le sénateur et
compte donc utiliser le mécanisme
d'arbitrage qu'ils ont eux mêmes mis en
place claude carignan glee housakos et
james cameron sont ceux qui se sont
d'abord entendu sur la nomination de
l'ex juge ian binnie chargé de trancher
si des sénateurs contestent l'ordre de
rembourser en plus d'expliquer leur cas
ils doivent donc défendre l'intégrité du
processus de choses à partager est
parfait parce que en un juge un des plus
grosses autorités une des plus grandes
autorités au canada que personne peut
questionner son indépendance son
impartialité mais dans les couloirs du
sénat on sent déjà le malaise pour
plusieurs la question se pose comment
peuvent-ils faire le ménage s'il n'était
pas blanc comme neige au départ
le sénateur la rue cambon suggère qu'il
devrait céder à d'autres la gestion de
la crise et la liste ne s'arrête pas là
selon nous sources parmi les neuf cas
qui seront référées par le vérificateur
général a grc c'est son libero trois
sont conservateurs dont une des vedettes
du parti pierre hugues boisvenu l'autre
sénateur qui siège toujours au sénat
serait le libéral colin kenny plusieurs
autres seraient des sénateurs dont rose
marie losier cool roads me marie charest
de poulet donald oliver et jerry saint
germain
madeleine pierre hugues boisvenu donc
siègera dorénavant comme indépendant
tout cas pour un certain temps ils
promettent s'expliquer au cours des
prochains jours mais d'ici là c'est un
dur coup pour les conservateurs de oui
c'est un dur coup céline parce que
pierre hugues boisvenu était le champion
de la loi et l'ordre du parti
conservateur est à quatre mois des
élections ils viennent de perdre
finalement une vedette alors que c'est
pour eux une priorité qu'ils avaient
l'intention de marteler en campagne
céline c'est aujourd'hui que le rapport
du vérificateur général a été remis au
président du sénat et déjà on a été
témoin d'un premier contrecoup il n'y en
aura peut-être d'autres évidemment ce ne
sont pas que des sénateurs conservateurs
qui sont visés il y aura aussi des
sénateurs libéraux qui seront dans la
mire du vérificateur général mais c'est
quand même un problème qui risque un
d'incommoder davantage de premier
ministre stephen harper parce qu'on sait
que le chef du parti libéral justin
trudeau lui a décidé il ya plusieurs
mois déjà de retirer les sénateurs de
son caucus et je vous rappelle en
terminant céline que c'est mardi qu on
devrait connaître le détail de ce
rapport du vérificateur général très
bien merci beaucoup madeleine de rien au
revoir
et pour en connaître davantage sur le
sujet notamment sur le procès de filles
qui est en cours en ce moment je vous
invite à consulter notre dossier web
vous voyez l'adresse à l'écran